thank you
[Music]
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by.com
[Music]
nosotros
[Music]
youtube heroes
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
m
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
strangers
[Music]
um
that's refreshing tasty it is it's uh
refreshing i switched to a different tea
did you really yeah this is interesting
hey
there's a lot going on right now in the
news yeah there's a lot going on with uh
with whoopi goldberg really double down
got worse i don't think she should have
been fired just to be clear but uh you
know i'll take the win
um
there's what's the name of the guy in
the nfl brian flores okay gerald is
going to explain that story because they
don't follow sports but we also we're
starting our brackets of the great
dictator off between hitler and mao
really hitler and mao and they're top
content whoever wins goes against stalin
and then mussolini oh geez so uh and
there there are some strange comparisons
actually right now parallels between
mao's rhetoric and i should say his
direct quotes which we'll get into with
joe biden quoting him directly and also
people who work for him anita dunn uh
and what we're seeing today so there's
parallels between the ideas the policies
as well as not so much a parallel as
like a straight line
from mao
to the current dnc with like an arrow
the way the crow flies yeah just in case
we were doing research and i was like oh
they don't even hide it they literally
say i like mao it's in the sources i i
just i know all the references available
at uh ladderscripter.com uh by the way
before we move on if we're not on
youtube if ever you watch this just
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern
we are always here if we're not here on
youtube that means we're on rumble that
means we're on mug club we do another
hour of show on mug club today we have
another segment we have steven no sports
so please that's the best way you can
support us um
also before well hold on gerald a how
are you i'm well how are you i'm doing
well i'm doing okay i'm going to file a
lawsuit about your hiring practices
though because i feel like you only
interviewed me just to meet a quota well
yeah
yeah certainly you have a certain number
of arians looking
gentlemen yeah yeah and we need token on
we need uh we need to uh slackjawed uh
quarter asians who
are zombified well he's looking at his
screen like
uh has his show is his show started he's
doing a job a lot to do over here
and then uh look he's here he's going to
be in denver this weekend but uh i will
be actually doing some live shows with
him uh you can uh go to is it
liverpool.com tour dates slash tour just
slash tour okay that's what i thought
slash tour uh we will be together in um
evansville indiana march 26th at the
victory theater he'll be in denver this
weekend dave landa how are you good ahoy
how are you i'm doing fine you sound a
little low compared to me now he's
everything do i sound a little
in no you can't and it is the victory
theater we accidentally wrote victoria
uh because um it was this the theater
made the best
i know it actually was on their mind
they sent it to us it was nice
the theater sent us the wrong name of
their own theater listen
it was a tough monday right
by the way hey just so everybody knows
we're going to be adding more dates to
that calendar we're also going to add
all the dates for dave probably in the
next couple of days but uh got a little
cool tour with you two going around the
country i hope we send you into like a
real commie you know blue state and see
what happens right yeah i needed a new
furnace so come out this weekend please
dave's furnace by the way before i move
on you know we're having a cold front
moving into texas oh there might be some
ice and this morning gerald comes in and
he tells me and john a canadian and then
of course uh dave a midwesterner he says
hey there's going to be ice so uh you
know we might just have to call off work
i was a humble can't drive i thought it
was a joke i thought it was a funny joke
we all laughed about it he was serious
i'm 100 i still am serious freezing rain
you can't drive on ice well especially
in texas all right look before i get to
the question today
comment below and tell gerald
how sad that looks do you remember that
i lived in the mids west i can't drive
in freezing rain what
yes you can no no when the road is iced
over and nobody preps the roads you
can't the only reason you can do it in
the north is because you have salt and
sand trucks every five minutes oh my god
where could they find salt we don't have
them it's because you have salt trucks
here you have sands like idiots well i
know that's what i'm saying
and then they're talking the news about
it people in texas get terrified
terrified uh when you get out this one
on the news broadcast when you go to
your car this morning you may see
something a small film on your
windshield commonly referred to as frost
yeah and this can be taken care of with
a solution that's one part vinegar one
part witch hazel and one part eye of
newt
just rush out and get bread and milk so
your whole family has gas well this is
like when you you northerners had a heat
wave of 94 degrees and people were dying
we're laughing at you like come on 110
is what we see now he's laughing at
death yeah no i'm laughing at you
sorry we don't have a dry heat yeah for
crying out loud not everyone can be from
phoenix mr perfect all right speaking of
perfect um
everyone here knows that second to olive
garden
i am a golden corral fan who is not
uh and
a fight broke out have you ever been
there
i
alex i walked in once with my father
because you know it was the only uh type
of uh restaurant where they they decided
that the real estate at the airport was
most prudent so we were had that we had
the killing in there yes no no no it was
walmart greeters and um
very cultured
yeah uh yeah it's an ethnic yeah yeah
tuesday so we walked out
uh i saw the chocolate fountain and i
saw a kid sticking his booger finger i
was like no no that's not for me but for
some people look they they live for it
they they they love it
different strokes also many people at
golden girl have strokes
uh fight broke out golden corral because
of a stake
shortage
which uh was biden refers to it a
tremendous victory here it is the melee
the person throw a folding chair no it's
the kid's chair that's the high high
chair well where's the kid well thank
god they're out of it pretty sure they
shuffed him out
get up kid
the prize is the worst steak you've ever
had right
it's still going oh yeah this is no
longer about the state guy picks up the
table realizing come on that's like when
black lives matter it's no longer about
the destruction of the nuclear family
you're just looking for an excuse to
loot at that point someone's looking to
service themselves in the snee shield
jeff foxworthy is the uh
spokesperson so there could just be an
episode of are you smarter than a fifth
grader
and you're not
are you smarter than a fifth grader who
gets shoved out of his hat chair i was
surprised at how quick some of those
people that wheeled themselves in ran
out when there was a fight
i yeah that's true i'm surprised isn't
it called covered corral now i didn't
even know it's still golden corral yeah
it's golden omicron yeah what is golden
about the corel there the the colostomy
bags
uh where's butch cassidy in sundance
when you need him can't they just go out
shooting i mean how many dreadlocks do
you think were left on the ground yeah
well yeah i don't know if people are
going to walk in some january's like
this is a golden corral or a wnba game
yes yeah so is this a spirit airlines
conference what happened todd that's the
seventh fight that's broken out there
over stakes yeah so many ghetto snakes
just left
i don't know what they have bruce buffer
they're announcing and in this corner we
have listeria no they actually ran out
of a1 because it's the only way you can
eat one of their steaks so and ketchup
but how does that happen when you're out
of steaks and it's like well i guess we
just have to beat the [ __ ] out of each
other yeah exactly i mean that
do you think that'll make the chuck
roast uh up here it can't hurt
someone get my oxygen chain quick quick
nail them i mean what this is why i
don't know this is a sad state of
affairs it really and you know what this
is a problem where this wouldn't
escalate if the person who probably
started it there was one instigator got
punched in the mouth initially
that's the problem there needs to be you
need to you need to find the leader of
the pack in this case probably someone
who's 75 years old take them out and you
wouldn't have that
you can't punch a 75 year old if it's
another 75. oh that's true or you're
like ate the last steak yeah
it's kind of it's kind of a good thing
that they did dave right so you hate you
hate golden corral type places right
yeah and is it the sneeze i mean i like
the problem yeah exactly
well it's not even just about not a fan
of
it's just a personal body odor in the
room i was the one that ran out of
chicken there was three dead guys yeah
and it's like it's a sneeze shield
guard you don't have to test it right
exactly no it does work i did one time i
was at a golden crawl i kid you not and
i i wanted to advertise something yeah
yeah i grew up poor so yeah golden
corral was part of the uh you grew up
making poor choices go on right so there
was a spoon and i was like i haven't
tried that before i literally i picked
up this you've never tried a spoon
before i don't know whatever what it was
in i can't remember the sauce or
whatever it was and i looked they
weren't a utensil and i'm looking i'm
staring in the eyes of the attendant
who's going and i'm like
[Laughter]
how do you know any better i was like
nine years old for people listening on
audio gerald just had the story of the
week it won't make sense unless you see
it that actually happened i was 100 true
i didn't know any better i was i was
below the sneeze guard height right so
everything was at eye level i was like
i'll try that golden corral or as the
chinese buffet owners call it those
cocky bastards with the a health rating
you go home yeah when you go in they
basically go do you want to sit uh sex
offender or non-sex offender
i just have the forms to fill out to let
everyone know in the smoking section
just let them know i'm sorry it's maps
please hey are you a lot of smoke in
here yet no but yeah
sir we care very little about the
smoking it's really the raping and
pillaging that will ensue lately i saw a
guy there who was just morbidly
morbidly obese well yeah in just
overalls like this because that's all he
could nothing underneath it nothing
underneath it you should definitely not
be at a buffet like morbidly
he put the chocolate fountain on his
plate like it was everything he covered
everything with it
banjo from deliverance play it was like
that though i don't know where he is i
assume not above ground no but
it is just so filled with garbage and if
you eat there i just want you to know
you i think you're trash yeah oh look
well that's true yeah
you're right it's not a character
indictment except um it absolutely is
it's a character indictment it's like
cece's pizza
like pieces used to be
decent like bad but okay right like yeah
decently bad
i grew up in canada we did not have ccs
did you have like pizza buffets though
right yeah uh no they changed no not
where i grew up no i mean well uh pizza
hut had the sunday buffet yeah they
changed it to feces pizzas
now it's wildly popular totally
yeah you know what you're getting into
yeah well that's a whoopi goldberg it's
for all the feces and giggles
golden corral i like their shrimp i like
jumping on something that looks like a
wrestler's ear child that's a good
sponsorship for her
is there a more terrifying phrase
language try the shrimp at golden corral
try the sushi at the golden girl listen
there's a virus out there we all need to
lock ourselves inside i'm sorry i've had
shrimp at golden corral i'm fine yes you
can go wherever yes you can
that's your golden corral i've also
enjoyed uh one or two mollusks at bob
evans you're certain to die soon
yeah yeah i still want pet and olive
garden yeah well olive garden is just
aggressively mediocre it is and they try
to act like it's not that's what bothers
me right well they act like they're the
second coming of italian christ yeah it
was his last miracle jesus made the
never-ending bread bowl right yeah do
you want never-ending breadsticks and
you have first of all they're terrible
which is how do you do that with
breadsticks they used to be good it's a
skill yeah yeah never ending sounds like
do i want never-ending [ __ ]
wow thanks i don't know hold on let me
think about it so when i finish this i
can get more something that's awful
right that's great yeah and i pay you
for it wow do i have to finish this see
you every day
oh wait you can you can eat a meal and
take a meal that's a great combo
it's like a penny dish it's take a bread
stick leave a bread yeah i can take this
home when it's soggy and worse wow i
can't wait
okay hey by the way before i move on
just this is always it's always
interesting to me who do you think was
worse hitler or mao we're going to do a
segment on that later but i want to see
you comment now then comment beneath it
and see if you're uh see if your opinion
has changed it's really actually pretty
fun for us to see someone say like oh
definitely hitler worse and then
underneath it like
i was wrong wow who knew there's no
hitler's chicken at golden corral no no
there isn't general mouse
i don't think i know it's served in a
tank bread bowl
could be people or dog we have no idea
no we do have an idea served for dessert
try the tiananmen naimo scores ah
tasty what's this red sauce they light
us like saganaki
what's that bake alaska no baked
dissident yeah that's a wonderful uh
no sucking like he's the flaming cheese
sorry
that would be funny though the point is
this
golden corral is why isis may have a
point
that's why the lawyers are going to call
us this afternoon right yeah never
mention our client again
and we're going to say well look the
problem is that you have golden corral
as a client yeah that's not you're not
really a respectable law firm what are
you a slip and fall you're a slip and
choke law firm slip and listeria law
firm you're a food poisoning law firm
let's be honest here you call your
clientele livestock yes
it's a corral do you understand what
you're saying all right this has been 15
minutes on golden corral let's move on
here we talked about this yesterday
i've enjoyed it speaking of speaking of
beasts of the field whoopi goldberg we
spoke of her yesterday yes she's gotten
big uh
she needs a walker look when you need a
walker and it's not due to age
you need to make some tyrell yeah
that's why people go in with walkers it
becomes a weapon that's true yeah you
know take off a little half tennis ball
there's a blade underneath it's true ah
so uh whoopi goldberg look she's been
canceled from the viewers she's been
temporarily suspended now i don't think
that she should have been we talked
about yesterday just how unbelievably
out of touch she was with her comments
regarding the holocaust not being about
race
i just the phrases are coming out of my
mouth that are real
these are actual things someone went on
a nationally televised program and said
the holocaust wasn't about race
okay um well she went on stephen colbert
to clear it up and one does yeah
one doesn't want to clear the area if
you're seeking grace from a forgiving
audience who will be understanding
you go to mr colbert
you want to make sure as many people
hear you as possible yes exactly can you
get rid of the dancing needles this is
serious
i i have to apologize but not get rid of
the dancing pfizers that's crazy we're
bringing out dancing aesthetics yes
but it's not about race
okay uh she tried to clear up her
comments on stephen colbert but she
ended up
making it i don't want to say
significantly worse so i'll go with much
have you have you come to understand
that the nazis saw it as race
because they might like asking the nazis
they would say yes it's a racial issue
well see this is what's interesting to
me because the nazis lied
it wasn't
they what they had issues
with ethnicity
not with race because most of the nazis
were white people and most of the people
they were attacking were white people so
to me i'm correct how can you
how can you say it's about race if you
are fighting each other so namely they
said it really began because i said how
will children how will we explain to
children what happened in nazi germany
this wasn't
i said this wasn't racial
this was about white on white
and everybody said no no no it was
racial and so that's what this all came
from so once again
don't write me anymore i know how you
feel i can't read okay i already know i
get it and uh
i'm going to take your word for it
yeah can someone get her a nice pop-out
book does whoopi come on after keenan
thompson
what's up with that
she's jason
was the running man
did she seriously end on i'll take your
word for it yeah yeah well you know what
maybe take the uh take the six million
uh you know six million lives for it can
somebody get this woman a briefer it
would be like this it would be just like
a couple of hear whoopi read this it
should just read holocaust was racist
oh now i know
she'd not understand that anti-semitism
is racism well i also don't understand
look maybe you guys can comment because
ethnic cleansing the idea it's not about
race it's about ethnicity like
i mean if you're killing someone based
on yeah isn't that i mean i certainly
think it's more racist than for example
like saying blue lives also matter i
certainly think that ethnic cleansing
you know six million people because of
their ethnicity
is more race
i don't know maybe you know this could
be the point where i've just you know in
my early 30s i'm out of touch yeah i
mean it's like what do you need a
reporter like stick a microphone and
hitler's face is like so is this about
race yeah
why do people keep asking me this i
don't know how much how
look let me spell it out for you copy
see some easy
see them
whatever i'll just get in trouble uh if
you're gonna say
white on white crime as she put it is
the problem yeah should we just handle
that then with all communities yeah
because she's trying to say seriously
how do we tell our kids about what
happened in the holocaust right white on
white and i'm like i think you're
missing the point she's also culturally
appropriated their name well that's true
well they are white but it doesn't mean
it's not racism yeah that's a part two
yeah i was talking to my friend last
night is jewish right her name's not
goldberg she took the name she went the
opposite to succeed in hollywood right
wow it's kind of
is there anti-semitism coming from
whoopi oh no my name's smith that
goldberg goldberg steen what do you
think all right berg you know what i
want gold and the berg yeah i'll take
both cause i'm golden and i'm ethnic
yeah
now here's the thing too that is
i don't think she should have been
suspended for two weeks i think she has
an opinion i think she's wrong i think
people have the right to be wrong
exactly that being said
do you think that stephen colbert would
have had that same grace for any kind of
a conservative guest do you think whoopi
goldberg would have i mean you're
talking about goldberg who went after
ben carson yeah for effectively being an
uncle tom because he was employed by
donald trump whoopi goldberg assumed was
racist when she said something that was
blatantly i don't want to say i don't
want to say racist i don't think that
whoopi goldberg has hatred in her heart
for jews okay i want to be clear about
this i don't think that she has disdain
for jews but i think she's certainly
more insensitive if you're going to tell
people to check their white privilege
because they don't believe that there is
systemic racism at universities today or
at a government level if you're going to
tell white people that they're racist if
they make that statement then you would
absolutely have to apply it here as far
as whoopi goldberg being privileged and
ignorant in not understanding that six
million people were killed because of
their race or ethnicity yeah that's
black privilege is is basically saying
that you're the only person that can be
uh discriminated against and have racism
against the united
are you not states
i would kill you too they really hated
that jesse owens came in and actually
cleaned their clock right hitler was
like by the way you mean karen elaine
johnson is ignorant of six million jews
that's her name
elaine johnson yeah yeah that's what i'm
saying she took on the name whoopi
goldberg it's not anywhere near her oh
my gosh
you succeed in hollywood
why did you pick whoopi goldberg well i
picked the first name because i like to
make whoop and just ask rodman i picked
the second one because i want people to
read my resume and give me a job and
then be surprised when i walk in the
door see the smile on their faces it's
crazy because whenever i would get up to
do stand-up people would go
whoopee
[Laughter]
more of a one-woman show yeah i come out
of my turtleneck say i am born and [ __ ]
it's real it's really introspective
esoteric you know
by the way you know those applause signs
were like flashing like on a blink right
just to make sure people half of the
audience is like
almost nobody said just imagine donald
trump jr imagine anyone in this room
imagine nick depaulo imagine uh take
your pick here imagine jenna ellis going
on stephen colbert and making that
justification and stephen colbert not
turning to try and get some clapter but
imagine david letterman how hard he
would have gone into bill o'reilly right
but it but appropriately yeah
no he did yeah and he did when he yeah
but he still had him on as a guest and
consider him a friend
i didn't know that they considered each
other friends well maybe not a friend
but he definitely considered him you
know a guest right okay
so uh she was suspended from the view
for two weeks correct this is abc news
president kim godwin said uh effective
immediately i am suspending whoopi
goldberg for two weeks for her wrong and
hurtful comments while whoopi has
apologized i've asked her to take time
to reflect and learn about the impact of
her comments yeah that always works with
adults it does you go sit in the corner
yeah i can't fit she needs two minutes
and a google search that's all she needs
to learn that she's in new york there's
the holocaust museum right there go talk
to some and tell them it wasn't about
race and see what they say is there a
diary she can pick up or something i
mean yeah there's a few movies you could
watch about it maybe on a loop yeah she
probably watches schindler's list i
could have done so much more you did
enough child
get over it you had a list oh my gosh
i'm gonna watch the color purple with me
[Laughter]
well there's real racism all right uh
this is another story speaking of racism
right now it's just amazing how much the
left is shipping their hands should be
suspended i do want to agree with you on
that because i think the problem though
i do want to say with cancel culture
is that it that whole show and it is
karma is based on cancelling everyone
right she is getting a taste of her own
medicine but i do feel that if we side
with it we're just being as bad as i
agree is there a diabetes medicine what
is it that she does the drug uh drug ads
for they going to drop her the more
she's like doing tai chi isn't she uh
well isn't she um bad what's the word
she's sick no
i dyslexic oh i don't think you take
medicine for that no i think dyslexic is
when you think that uh
the holocaust wasn't about it yeah
that's a new definition for dyslexia
anyway go on with yourself i read it
like hollow cost like it was free yeah
like the cost was hollow you know i
didn't know i thought hollow man then i
thought i saw kevin bacon's penis on
that getting that fail yeah i got
distracted it looked good
i want to taste it does it taste like
bacon his name's bacon six degrees
chocolate all right now we're going to
talk about what's going on in the nfl
another racist story before we get to
hitler mao uh but i don't know a whole
lot about the nfl so this is time for
gerald actually no sports
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so the only thing i know about
the miami dolphins is dan marino and
that's because i watched ace ventura
there you go so tell me out what is
going on this guy brian flores head
coach brian flores has filed a class
action lawsuit he purports to represent
40 other individuals and he's he's
saying that the nfl's hiring practices
for black coaches were racist so let me
just give you just a little information
about this he's suing three teams right
now he's fired by the miami dolphins
after three seasons i'm sorry i just i'm
sorry at a certain point i just
i i don't have any shits left to give i
mean the nfl well yeah you're talking
about the significant
portion i think the majority of nfl
players but now they're saying yeah but
not enough coaches well here's the thing
it's like coaches and people in the
front office and it's like we got a lot
of assistant coaches sure not enough
blah blah blah
so three teams that are being sued the
dolphins broncos and giants and let's
just keep in mind that one of the
reasons that he was fired is because in
three seasons he went 24 and 25 with the
miami dolphins so wow 24 and 25 now i
know like that you may think this is
like baseball and he can turn it around
at the end of the year with 170
something games i'm gonna take that for
sure that's not true i know it's like
150 but anyway he that's really bad he
was paid three million dollars a year to
uh achieve three million dollar
mediocrity okay yes so this is almost
like colin kaepernick getting paid yeah
it's just like roots right so according
to what is out right now he's alleging
the dolphins owner stephen ross 12 years
a coach incentivized him i'm just going
to keep going to tank in 2019 by
offering a hundred thousand dollars per
loss now that's pretty interesting
because that would just increase the the
position of your draft so if you lose
the most games you know like detroit
dave you guys are familiar with number
one picks you guys get to pick first and
maybe get the best athlete and so a lot
of times detroit gets number one picks
and they're still detroit lions oh yeah
yeah
we just don't do much really poorly with
them okay yeah right i i'd insult him
back but he's just right i'm right
but i want i want them to be better i
know you do their quarterback is going
to the super bowl this year he's just no
longer with their team i know your
heart's in the right place
so flores says right the problem with
detroit is there's just so much
ethnicity right there's not a race so
this is about race right this whole
lawsuit race right he says that he was
try he was pressured to illegally
recruit a prominent quarterback i'm not
sure how that's about race and this is
how his lawyer flores his lawyer
described the situation
and litigation is not for everyone but
he stepped forward
he's been referred to as the rosa parks
of the nfl by you and
it's testament to his character
and the litigation will create change
really can a reporter just ask i just
want one of those people at the desk
just when he goes yeah he's referred to
as aurora i want without skipping one of
those reports that's absolutely not true
well first of all she took the bus
because she was making roughly three
million dollars yes exactly yeah you're
exactly like rosa parks with your three
million dollars in her gold-plated bus
pass
what bus are you at the back of because
i would like to be there too oh my gosh
it's a pretty nice the rosa parks of the
nfl well and he's saying basically that
these they would sick dogs on him if he
sat in the run yeah exactly
so the nfl's had a problem rosa parks
had a had a uh what's it called one of
those executive boxes yes
well everybody in the industry you can't
be in the front of the executive box you
got to be at the back with the shrimp
yeah get back by the
golden corral
we had it brought in special why
the fact that a white guy said that okay
look i i'm gonna i'm gonna jump back on
what i said it won't be that guy should
lose his job well yeah before you move
on let's play that clip one more time
yeah let's just put it out let me just
see it one more time
he had a queue up over here and
litigation is not for everyone but he's
stepped forward um
he's been referred to as the rosa parks
of the nfl yeah and
they just caught it
yeah they're just not like yes
yes that's the chatter rosa parks of the
nfl do you see the black guy he didn't
move at all the white guy's like yeah
that must be right the black guy's like
what what'd you just say i was like i'm
about to rosa parks and get up off this
chair beat your ass like seriously
he's been referred to the frederick
douglass of the nfl yes yes yeah because
you're totally he basically is saying
like it's an nfl plantation again
they're using this plantation word
making millions of dollars a year i'm
like okay all right well barry bonds
harriet tubman yeah again would have
nothing to do with rosa parks
yes because rosa parks 2 was on a
plantation yeah on that bus the name of
the bus was plantation i know the
alabama bus boycott
yes so it also alleges that the giants
only interviewed him to satisfy what's
called the rooney rule rooney steelers
owner because there was racism in hiring
right they were like oh we're not gonna
put a black guy in charge but guess who
the head coach of the the pittsburgh
steelers is right now mike tomlin who is
black
and they say he didn't change his name
to goldberg
his brother or woman yeah
so they say there's only a an interview
quota not a hiring quota and he's saying
although it was just a sham interview
well you interview five or six
candidates a lot of times and of course
some are more popular than others but
you had a 24 and 25 years but here's the
problem someone who doesn't follow
sports they have an interview quota
meaning you have to meet with a certain
amount of black people right okay
and you can't be mad if they met with
you for an interview with no intention
of hiring you right that's the whole
point that's what's silly about quotas
if you are not qualified or if you have
a losing record and they go all right
well we need it well we got to meet with
some black guys i don't know bring him
in again that's the
this is one it's the same issue with the
affirmative action in colleges yeah when
people go uh you know for the rest of my
life i have to deal with people uh
looking at me like did he really deserve
to be at that university well exactly
that's the problem that's why it's a
problem it should be merit-based there
should be no quotas whatsoever i
understand back in the day right right
but
not i mean let's not act like the nfl
today is a bastion of white
conservatives well if you're a good head
coach i mean look at all of the head
coaches that lose their job every single
year there's usually several positions
jim caldwell at the detroit lions was a
great head coach he lost his job oh yeah
you definitely so you're telling me
right now and there may be fine maybe
there's a couple of racist owners out
there fine i'll give you that i have no
idea
you're telling me that they are willing
to take a chance on black players coming
to their team to help them win but so
the racism stops at players but the guy
who's most directly responsible for
making sure the team wins they're like
well that's where i draw the line don't
really take that chance on black players
that's not really a role of the well no
but like you're saying it only hurts
you're saying they're racist owners
they're only okay
yeah you're at the player roulette table
you bet on black always that on black
well because it's all black with one red
correct
yeah that's mike yeah that's not yeah
yeah so this is kind of funny this is
the first page of the lawsuit and they
say as this class action complaint is
filed on the first day of black history
month we honor the brave leaders like
they bring dr martin luther king in here
they have a quote it's also kind of
funny on the first page
sorry a lot of people don't know his i
have a dream to coach arena football
oh yeah it has nothing to do with the
fact that it's the end of the season
right
he gets fired and he's alleging that his
hiring isn't he's not going to get hired
somewhere because he's just he's window
dressing to me also yeah exactly all
right it's 24-25 yeah you're right they
weren't taking you seriously yes
nobody will be yeah seriously
that'd be like mike tyson saying i am
ferocious my defense is impenetrable if
he had lost 25 fights right
but i won 24. i don't i don't think that
these people are not intimidated from by
me because i am a black man no it's
because you've lost 25 fights well that
might play a factor but i think ra
ethnicity as well
50 of the time i win 100 of the time
that's right hey guys actually i just i
have a quote from whoopi goldberg
apparently this also was not about race
so it's about ethnicity yeah exactly
it's not about race it's just black on
black hate crime in the nfl when someone
excuses something with a synonym for the
thing they said that was wrong
look if anything else comes out about
this we'll reassess it not sexist
because she's a woman because we're
talking about a lady not a woman the
problem
okay
okay it's the problem with with
professional sports is
if you're hired be and you're black for
some reason it's racist and if you're
not it's racist colin kaepernick said
that it was modern slavery the combat
yeah yes but while
casting a commercial of slaves yeah
expecting people yeah so it's turning
away people that didn't look slaved
enough because the slaves all had
tattered burlap pants with nike logos
yeah the nfl is one of the that were
made by slaves yes the nfl is one of the
best places for meritocracy yeah in the
world and it's not just about your
ability to perform on the field it's
also your ability to lead in the locker
room and not be a distraction some teams
will take more chances on people being
distractions antonio brown with the
bucks obviously going off during the
middle of the game and throwing his pads
and running into the locker room you
missed on that one coach i don't
understand the reference but most of the
people watching do so that's okay right
but if you like like read the safety who
basically was you know kaepernick and
reed were the two guys that were filing
suit against the nfl kaepernick was a
terrible quarterback reed was actually a
good safety but he wasn't good in the
locker room from what a lot of people
heard because if you can play if you can
do it they will give you an opportunity
people get second chances that have
criminal records that are recent heck
the raiders moved to las vegas and
killed two people in two seasons uh
that's terrible dick butkus i just
wanted to be in clown in the sports
segment all right let's move on here too
yes
mike ditka the bears
uh sure this has been gerald no sports
[Applause]
[Music]
now i want to get to something that is
uh again really scary you heard me talk
about this with trudeau uh i think
monday maybe it was tuesday
and you are seeing the terrifying
totalitarian
tyrannical-like statements being echoed
by this administration this is not
hyperbole so this uh gen saki was asked
about spotify and the warnings and joe
rogan let's be honest this is not about
warnings warnings are the first step we
saw that with youtube where we were
getting slapped with warnings and then
we were suspended for quoting the cdc
look behind you there's the slippery
slope okay it's not a logical fallacy if
it is actually taking place now
she was asked the press secretary
jensaki uh about the warning labels on
spotify and i also want this is the the
problem
like we just talked about yesterday uh
we had it live for brian stelter or the
day before where he was complaining that
people trusted joe rogan more than him
look people will trust you more if you
just come out of the closet with your
man bag and i'm like all right okay i
was at the golden at least he was honest
how did they not trust me they're out of
chuck roast you guys he
started getting someone with his purse
the man bag get the kid's chair
yeah he threw all the stakes in his
louis vuitton
they're completely out i can't believe
it i don't have enough room get my kate
spade from the car they're out of stake
the complete way that i'm not out
[Laughter]
so saki was asked about the warning
labels on spotify and this is specific
when people say spotify right now
warning labels on spotify let's be clear
they are talking about singling out joe
rogan like him or hate him if you
support
not only freedom of speech but when
we're talking about cancel culture i
understand that spotify can choose to
have whatever they want on their
platform here's the issue
you are not dealing with a free market
because the outrage is not coming from
the market the outrage is coming from
the top down sort of like with the nfl
the outrage is not coming from the
viewers the outrage is coming from the
media executives who tell them that they
need to be more woke and in this case
with spotify you have members of the
media colluding with uh members of this
administration who then when people talk
about dog whistles this isn't a dog
whistle jen saki watch her answer she
says and i want everyone on these big
tech platforms basically saying hey look
you better start doing our bidding for
us and more importantly when you see the
incestuous relationship listen to how
this question is framed to jen saki it
doesn't even allow for the possibility
that anyone in the room
may think it's troubling watch this
entire exchange spotify is putting out
uh advisory warnings on episodes that
have to do with kobe 19. does the white
house and the administration think this
is a satisfactory step or do you uh do
you think that companies like spotify
should go further than just you know
putting a label on there doesn't even
allow the option maybe it's wrong to
check this out you know there's more
research you can look at you know
scientific research regarding coping
sure well last july
you probably know but the surgeon
general also took the unprecedented step
to issue an advisor on the risk of
misinformation in public health which is
a very significant step and amid that he
talked about the role social media
platforms have so our hope is that all
major tech platforms and all major news
sources for that matter be responsible
and be vigilant to ensure the american
people have access to accurate
information on something as significant
as covid19 that certainly includes
spotify so this disclaimer
but we want every platform to continue
doing more to call out misinformants and
disinformation while also uplifting
accurate information we want all of the
tech platforms and media to be vigilant
if you see something say something also
she says spotify you got that from
kamala harris i call it spotify uh first
asian uh president vice president but
here's something else that's interesting
there you know she mentioned the surgeon
general hey
do you remember early on on this
pandemic and we were actually working
with uh jaco willing's show uh not a
show his uh company uh i can't remember
what it was called origin
uh no it was jocko where they were
releasing clothes and they started
releasing masks we on this program in
april of 2022 said look if you're going
out uh if you're sick the best way to
create a mask uh sorry in 2020 actually
we're 20 20. gosh it's been going on for
two years
please just kill me kill me no
what 2020 we said look if you're going
to make a mask at home here's what you
want to double ply we said like a mixed
poly blend uh a pillow case we showed
people how to wear a mask if they were
sick and they had to go to work this was
before we had two weeks to flatten the
curve at that time it's interesting
because gensake just brought up the
surgeon general the surgeon general of
the united states if you don't remember
and i'm sure the control room can bring
this up was tweeting don't wear masks
they do nothing please everyone stop
buying masks and now you're saying well
the surgeon general has issued this and
we need to trust the surgeon general for
misinformation the surgeon general
spread misinformation we get it now you
said well we lied because we needed more
ppe for hospital workers but the problem
remains we can't trust you you lied and
you are saying we should be trusted and
of course media big tech follow suit do
what we ask
what if when you ask
or what if what you ask is wrong like
your surgeon general saying don't go buy
masks like
your
vice president saying i won't take the
vaccine
because it's been developed under trump
so did joe biden what if it's like hey
you know uh the vaccine allows it allows
you to go out and live your lives again
because you can't transmit it what if
big tech who you are requesting out
there to follow your lead in media and
that is the result of misinformation on
spotify what if by your request they're
spreading your misinformation because
what you are claiming today is accurate
information
it's yesterday's misinformation exactly
well i think their whole point is that
it's not misinformation if it comes from
us right no matter what it is and you
know what this brings me to this brings
me right back to what i said about
trudeau look if any of your leaders
that isn't quite there yet jin saki
but trudeau
just because in pardon my language if
you have kids just because he's a [ __ ]
with a capital p and a coward doesn't
mean that he's not a tyrant this is one
of the scariest quotes i've ever heard a
world leader
ever in my lifetime speak out loud
small fringe minority
of people who are on their way to ottawa
or who are
holding unacceptable
views that they're expressing
do not represent
the views of canada that's enough you
can stop the clip that's enough holding
unacceptable views anytime your leader
says these people are holding
unacceptable views they got to go
they've got to go you don't get to
determine what's an acceptable view just
like jen saki doesn't get to determine
what is misinformation if in fact hey is
she a scientist because that's the
rebuttal we always hear are you a
scientist i don't know is she because
spotify is going based on her word when
trudeau says
holding unacceptable views that's it you
already passed the line and ascend that
guy has to go and a fringe minority just
to keep it clear this is this freedom
convoy they've raised more money than
the major political parties in canada
that's how much of a fringe minority it
is
really and then i want to but let me
read you let me see if you can see some
similarities here uh very similar to
let's read the stalin quote the press
must grow day in and day out it is our
party's sharpest and most powerful
weapon lenin said why should freedom of
freedom of speech and freedom of press
be allowed why should a government which
is doing what it believes to be right
allow itself to be criticized
talk about
road to hell paved with good intentions
i want to read that part again why
should a government which is doing what
it believes to be right allow itself to
be criticized here's the thing let's
assume there's no ill intent i'll tell
you why it has to allow itself to be
criticized because you might be wrong
and right now you have a losing record
saki and by an administration like that
flores guy yeah losing record let's at
least call it a split record good
comparison quite a few draws the
dolphins here's another quote from
lennon it would not allow opposition by
lethal weapons ideas are much more fatal
things than guns well we can't allow
those uh on uh those those unallowable
views unauthorized unacceptable
unacceptable viewpoints right
i mean you're right that is chilling and
you need to understand that the
unacceptable view and this is where we
always go wrong it's like well yeah
maybe this view over here is is widely
unacceptable but his unacceptable view
is somebody being against a mandate not
being against a vaccine or not being
against having people protected from a
virus a government mandate is the only
thing just let us do it of our own free
will that was given to us by god because
i read the country south of us says that
yeah not us here's the thing too
what is required for it to be an
impermissible or what do you say
unallowable unacceptable unacceptable
view yeah all right
let's go through this okay because when
people say need to find common ground
i'm going to go through this with uh all
right let's go through it with right now
the vaccine the mandate and let's go
through it with climate change okay
so you can be
pro-personally vaccine okay
so i'm personally let's say someone says
i'm personally pro-vaccine okay i'm even
vaccinated like i believe it's 80
something percent of these truckers are
i'm even vaccinated okay and i think
that we should make it readily available
for the infirm and for people who are
vulnerable okay uh and i believe that we
should educate people on covet and i
believe we should okay but i don't
believe
in mandating that everybody be required
to have the vaccine unacceptable yeah
that's an unacceptable view where is the
common ground let's go through climate
change okay you can say look i believe
that there is climate change okay i
believe that humans may be a
contributing factor to it okay uh and i
believe that maybe it'll even have some
uh negative consequences in the long
term okay i simply don't believe that
the u.n
and china
and the rest of these world governments
getting together can do anything to
solve it unacceptable that makes you the
fascist yeah
well you disagree with the scientists
stephen that was the quote 95 of the
scientists agree right 97 or was it 97
but you that's the problem is especially
with the spotify thing you they can say
are you a scientist well the per people
rogan are is talking to they are the
scientists one of the guys was one of
the inventors of the mrna technology
right yes in opposing view
whether they're calling big tech is
simply all the information that you're
getting right that's what's so scary
about it yeah well and saki just wants
to silence
opposition
like that they have no idea what they're
playing with and if they do then they
are the most evil dictatorial people
that we have seen in power in the united
states probably in its history but i
think they lean to they don't really
understand what they are unleashing with
this because it's not the first person
that does it typically that's the
problem it's the next person that comes
in or the person after that that goes ah
the groundwork's already been laid all i
got to do is push it just a little
further and all of a sudden you have
people groups that go into concentration
camps you have people groups that are
killed by the millions we'll get to that
in just a couple of minutes with our
comparison of hitler and mao yep that's
how it happens were you about to say
something there token yeah i have an
exciting breaking news oh that means
it's horrible and it's gonna swallow
myself no no no no no so you'll remember
that chris cuomo he was you know fired
from cnn yeah there was this investment
right there was this investigation i
think that's what you're going to say
jeff zucker oh
and so what what happened was he was
having a relationship with alison gallus
who was the evp of marketing and she was
actually tied to giving governor cuomo
some information i guess or helping with
with you know the whole andrew cuomo
thing
he hadn't he had a relationship with her
so it was actually uncovered in that
investigation is he married so they were
investigating he said chris cuomo right
and then they found that jeff zucker was
also a scumbag zucker said i was
required to disclose it when it began
but i didn't
[Laughter]
rules for the and not for me baby and he
thought that wouldn't go anywhere he's
like yeah i should have but i
didn't and allison glush she had a lot
to lose too because she was actually uh
that was jeff zuckerberg embarrassing
for her she she was being considered to
replace him at one point in 2021 she was
right under him yeah
literally
what
so oh here's a statement from jeff
zucker on cnn right now you're watching
this in real time he said yes i
acknowledge the relationship evolved in
recent years i was oh oh let's bring up
reliable sources
oh i wanted to bang him i mean fire him
yes grateful to the thousands of
incredibly talented cnn and turner
sports employees success helped make
this such a joy for me how is he going
to afford his gomez atom suits
also they're they're both divorced and
sucker out okay all right well at least
it's
a few minutes ago
a stunner for the cnn newsroom and for
tournaments that's what he did this is
weird i'm sorry pulled a stunner years
now he's resigning over a consensual
relationship that he didn't disclose
amidst hold on amidst an incredible
unprecedented ratings drop yeah is
somebody seeing a ship sinking and go ah
the hell i've been sleeping with that
lady bye guys well i don't know if if
that's the case you better get rid of
stealth they're gonna run out of rations
and she she
was gonna stop daredevil before she was
hired as the evp of chief marketing um
this comes from the control room she was
andrew cuomo's communications director
oh wow so yeah of course we should trust
uh the the the government and those
immediate they're one and the same yeah
for do people understand that i mean
look at stephanopoulos i'm a guy who
worked with for the clintons do you guys
see this they are one in the same the
media and government that's the issue
and then when you have the government
saying we hope that all media and big
tech platforms this is why they're going
after rogan on spotify look it's really
easy to control the voices on cnn abc
nbc cbs it's really easy to control the
voices on colbert to really you're
talking about four major companies and
they're losing ground and then all of a
sudden once we end up in a legal issue
with uh whatever it is viacom whatever
whoever it is our subscribers that we're
going up 130 000 a month
stop exactly and then you see right now
i cannot get away from suggested seth
meyers videos i don't think anyone has
ever wanted a suggested set meyers video
but i do want to see what brian stelter
is saying here
he should have disclosed it right away
that is why he says he's resigned
effective immediately kate we both know
uh he uh jeff zucker has been the rock
for this organization the last few days
he has not
uh some people even notice and wonder if
something was amiss i don't think
anybody uh saw this coming this is hard
like this robbing but i think if zucker
was on that administration
he'd say what's important
is not the person at the top it's the
team we all play for it's cnn as an
organization this news operation so much
bigger than any single person and so the
news goes on but now without the top
executive i thought he was gonna be like
we are cnn and we people need to trust
us yeah no he can't say that with a
straight face well you can't say
anything with a straight face
we are the creamy news network yes
damn you dave
i hate him i don't even know why like
you know he's angling for that job
he thought he was getting cuomo's job
that's why i threw cuomo into the bus
and now he thinks he's going to get
zucker's job because he's a talentless
hack can someone out there genuinely and
you know you can comment below i have
not and we have a team of researchers i
have not been able to find any reason
that brian stelter has that job he had
some website yeah and he sold it and
then next thing you know he has a show
on one of the biggest news what dirt
does he have on something well zucker's
recite you know resigning so maybe yeah
maybe shelters on the way out i think
we're seeing the dirt in real time right
yeah well no it's funny after that
passed over manila envelope i hired a
private and guest investigator whoopsie
and that's it's a little soggy from the
stake in the well you know just dust it
off at the end of that uh little little
bit that they were doing there i don't
we cut away before you saw this he
actually was like oh what what what is
this in my it's my resume for president
of cnn yes
it's weird yes oh hang on my wife's
calling and it's my uh my headshot
i think you'll like what's on the back
they just turn it around it's the back
of his head so i think you'll
you'll be impressed
this is also my money shot yes
i have a lot of pictures
they're all gross
you can find more at stelter hub all
right uh this brings us on what we're
talking about while we're talking about
dictatorships
it's children brian stelter was dating
this lady from cnbc i don't believe it
no that's not true did he wear her on
his face like an actual physical baby
it's on the wikipedia page okay
yeah they put that on there like faction
i see her again
careful dave no i'm just looking he did
not no
oh no she didn't unless she hasn't been
seen for a few years
he swallowed her hole yeah that's nicole
lapin from scene she's a very
that's just a waste
yeah that really is i mean come on with
that no there's no way she's a cute
gayle there's no way it'll be one thing
you know look it'd be one thing to be
overweight and and clearly super
straight but it's another thing to have
although and also be entirely devoid of
charm
yeah so i don't know how he would i
don't believe it
maybe she's in a hall somewhere so he
can make a pair of socks yeah i mean
like to be fair
the the relationship was in 2011 so
brent stelzner was much younger
well i got that horseshoe but
she's even pulling away this yeah yes
fungus they're taking a picture please
please don't spoil it i walked in with
your mouth wrapped on something last
night
yeah it was zucker yeah he too was none
too thrilled like come on make me vp
you don't know where i've been oh my god
how old was he here
he is i'm sorry but that is not a good
looking news anchor
he must have a great personality that he
hides well
but none of those words had an alopecia
since he was 12 yeah i think i think he
was
it just makes sense he's like a bulldog
he was 26. was he really there
wow that was 26 year old brian 26 year
old brown stilter that's not good i
guess the years of popping who's on the
left there
chris cornell
[Music]
oh gosh well you know what cnn we hope
that you get a win sometime but don't
bank on it all right speaking of uh of
wins it's time to see now we're going to
create these brackets and go through
this over the next couple of weeks
because a lot of people you all know
about hitler but you don't know about
the other authoritarian tyrants who have
existed throughout time so this is time
now between hitler and mao our first
dictator off
[Music]
[Music]
that'll never be taken out of context
now let's
ever
the left of course that just i i know
you feel like this is remedial but uh
the media those in the left people like
stelter of course they've always been
they've always been using hitler and
dave made this great point yesterday if
you missed yesterday's show it's a
constant through line their comparison
to uh
any white male republican typically but
also black male republicans and black
female republicans they always point to
them and the comparison to hitler is
made ad nauseam
ruth when some of us call trump a
fascist last year we were told that
fascists control mobs and paramilitaries
and trump doesn't i mean he incited a
violent mob on january the 6th a lot of
voters didn't want to believe everything
that was obvious to so many of us that
donald trump is a fascist
and when it comes to democracy versus
fascism i'm sorry there are not fine
people on both sides
[Music]
okay so you get the gist here yes we get
the gist thank you for clarifying that
cnn
no can you expound reporting well they
seem to dislike america oh
aren't they multi-millionaires uh that's
irrelevant sir some of that is
international touring well if anybody
wants to know why i don't like green day
they're on the plantation too stephen
well i mean technically i think he
qualifies as a little person so he's
been oppressed
billy joe armstrong
yeah uh here's the other thing though
right so they always compare to hitler
but not only is barely any attention
given to uh these other horrible
dictators who by the way cost many more
lives we'll get to that
communism socialism that's they have to
be careful when you have someone in your
own party like bernie sanders saying
socialism or elizabeth warren said well
there are good elements to socialism
not only do they not mention it this is
something that is even more concerning
you know former both obama and biden
advisor i think she i think she retired
in 2021 don't quote me on it uh anita
dunn
said that mao was one of her favorite
figures and uh you'll also see former
vice president joe biden quote mao
unironically twice so not only do they
not distance themselves from it but
they just think well people don't really
know
mao is not you you say mouth like it's a
bad thing here you go and then the third
lesson
and tip
actually come from two of my favorite
political philosophers
mao say tongue and mother teresa
not often coupled with each other 51 of
the people in this country are women
that
that old expression goes women hold up
half the sky there's a saying we use in
a different context the chinese saying
it says women hold up half the world
yeah so here's the thing if the media
media's not going to fact-check like
isn't that a mao quote
isn't that an understatement uh his said
in a different context oh you mean like
the slaughter of millions of people
context is that the different context
tomato tomato you undersold that joe
there's an old chinese quote that's uh
if uh if uh you know you have a girl
baby you drown it yeah no
no because you need to have a boy baby
because they're gonna you know they
gotta make the money in the killing
field yeah there's too many people i
don't know and i don't know who paul was
what why had so many pots
oh is anybody else anybody else going
blind and they're right out here i'm
getting floaters all right so who was
actually worse hitler or mao now let me
be very clear
i'm not defending either
[Laughter]
[Applause]
they're both they're both bad it's just
which one is more badder oh we all agree
right most baddest oh we're going for
bad yes oh yes detroit lion's bad that's
yes detroit hey
and i think the next one is going to be
stalin whoever wins this one okay let's
look at the uh the policies specifically
so um hitler he created new deal style
policies right these job programs he
instituted rearmament which was illegal
at the time highways producing
international weapons now what was the
impact of that um well hitler actually
claimed full employment i don't know if
you know this by 1939 yeah and this is
something that sometimes actual white
supremacists use they say actually he
really helped with employment and he
helped bring back the robust economy
well the number is misleading because
that doesn't include the 1.4 million men
in the army the jews who were basically
ousted from their own jobs and of course
uh the women the rearmament too this is
sort of the origin not the origin but
certainly people who [ __ ] about the uh
the military-industrial complex well
what did this do
in uh germany at that time
50 increase in profits for big
businesses and again this is the
national socialist workers party of
germany it's always ironic that in every
form of socialism communism the big
businesses the ones with the big
contracts do well the medium the small
businesses they suffer and i'm going to
get back to that too as well with both
hitler and mao now um
here's another policy that he had uh the
hereditary exterminate six million jobs
and then bring them back so it's kind of
like the way biden's brought back he
didn't really bring them back per se
yeah he just took them and reallocated
them right yeah it was but that's kind
of how biden's done well we didn't count
the ethnic pool he also had the
hereditary farm law of 1933. uh this is
something that a lot of people don't
really know about what did it do
restricted farms to not just germans but
actually germans could only be those who
are german blood or the same tribe
whoever has jewish or colored blood
among his ancestors on his father's or
his mother's side is not of the german
or of the same trap so you could not own
the farms it had to be which as uh
whoopi goldberg says not racist not
racist at all not a racial colored blood
is it purple
it's great
so what's the impact the pragmatic so
let's say you agree with it in theory
because you're a racist well
agricultural prices went up about 20
percent okay so hitler really screwed
that up as far as the farms all right uh
worst thing about price of carrots yeah
find a carrot at a
golden corral have you been to the local
farmer's market oh the hitler corral
there are the carrots
i don't want any popcorn i don't want to
be popcorn okay so this is a steak at
the third corel he tightly regulated
small businesses a lot of people again
this matters because when people say oh
it was nationalism it wasn't socialism
no there was a lot of nationalizing
companies a lot of nationalizing entire
industries um so regulated small
businesses how did he do that commodity
prices he would fix those there'd be
these crazy interest rates the wages
were fixed by the government they
controlled how much was invested
distributed produced so um 20 of small
businesses closed under hitler now we're
not just talking about the jews here i
just want you to know what hitler
actually did as far as a fascist okay
we'll get to all the other stuff let's
look at mao he had the great leap
forward policies okay terrible so him
with agriculture
uh here's what he did all the households
were organized into communes
okay
and um private property markets were
abolished
for the greater good
just a greater good for the greater good
you'll hear this theme a lot for the
greater good um the communes directed
all agriculture local government uh they
managed all economic and social activity
all the resource allocation food
distribution and then here's the thing
too here's the problem let's say that
this is done with good intentions like
jen saki just before saying it would be
really good you know if they followed
the surgeon general's warning spotify
with misinformation okay let's assume
that your intentions are pure guess what
you could still be wrong
and that's the problem with
consolidation of power when people [ __ ]
about capitalism i've always pointed out
i said well sure i believe that people
in positions of power can be corrupt and
you see that with executives you see
that with some companies but there is at
least some form of a self-correcting
mechanism that doesn't happen when the
the power is consolidated to people who
are beholden to nobody so uh what would
happen to when it came to farming
in china because of mao anita dunn joe
biden big fans yeah they're in the right
they're in the mao fan club they have a
mouth wall
uh
they mandated practices these these
bureaucrats in urban areas in china like
overseeding over fertilizing and they
ended up just even though let's assume
they weren't evil they were just wrong
they ended up screwing up agriculture in
china so they had this four pests
campaign and that was to get rid of look
this makes sense flies sure mosquitoes
sure rats right sparrows what what do
they have wrong with sparrows well they
were stupid oh well so let's just say
they weren't evil we'll get to the 45
million people who died they were stupid
ah
so
people citizens were actually encouraged
to bang pots and pans to prevent
sparrows from landing because they
believe that the sparrows were killing
the crops again this is the problem or
when you have some picture you know
china but picture here someone in dc
telling someone in indiana how to run
their crops when they have no idea and i
don't mean telling them how much
you know they can yield or fixing prices
like we have here with cherries and with
milk which is absurd because we fix
prices i mean literally telling them
what standards and practices
in iowa you know that they have to use
for corn imagine anita dunn saying no no
no this is how you're going to uh this
is how you're going to farm corn that's
what happened in china and so they said
wow oh no no no can't have sparrow we'll
ruin crop
so one billion sparrows were killed wow
that's that's a lot everyone knows six
million jews yeah one billion you didn't
know one billion sparrows now you will
guys that wasn't we told sparrow they
were just taking shower
no and then what they falsified their
grain reports no there's gas coming out
of that bird feeder
that's that that's the trick that's not
that's not bird seed that's zyklon b yes
so local leaders falsified reports to
meet grain quotas and what happened
there was a 30 reduction in grain output
a lack of sparrows led to locust swarms
when the last time you heard about a
locust swarm here in the united states i
think it's moses it's moses and maui
you've never heard of a swarm of
sparrows coming as a plague in the bible
but you have for locusts and then peeps
people had to resort to eating uh like
tree bark and dirt what about the
billions sparrows don't they have some
meat well i just think they decompose
rather quickly oh well that's probably
not true
that's true you should eat the sparrow
you would think so
that's it's sparrow it's like mana fall
from sky
you thank dear leader
for bringing you mana be sure to uh boil
on hot because lots of virus now you
can't live on a free bar
i don't know rambo did it have you tried
but he was trained to eat the kinds of
things that would make a billy goat puke
i haven't tried personally but i have
tried four people hmm yeah what what
it was it was it was delta but he
thought it was for oh yeah it was a head
shot now uh what was the impact of this
with mao okay so again let's road to
hell paved with good intentions greater
good well the crop failure led to the
worst famine in recorded history and 45
million people died right that just for
context that is the largest non-military
killing of people in history right by
country okay that that would seem to be
you know that would be like a point in
his corner in this really diabolical
game of ours yeah yeah let's give that
that's one point mao let's give that
that's one point mao okay so mao has a
point the largest one in history when
we're dealing with uh not sure who they
passed but it's like they run out of bad
people to kill them like i would like
you but we've got to kill you for the
record and here's another example this
is very this can parallel to with today
where they're trying to force the green
industry right like solyndra they're
trying to force green technology they
just had another green uh an electric
airplane go down in flames um
there's nothing wrong with
industrialization it comes with
complications we're going from an
agricultural society right an agrarian
society to sort of a top-down society we
had an industrial revolution here in the
united states the problem is in china
and it was not without its problems in
the united states but in china they
tried to force it
they tried to force the markets through
what the power the coercion of
government and uh they were aiming to
actually double steel production double
steel production in one year so what did
that do let's say you go well that's a
good thing they want some more steel
okay 30 to 40
of uh the housing stock was demolished
to obtain raw materials for these
collective projects that's one way and
again this is all all of us so think
about it well hold on but that's that's
that's my house well it's yeah it's for
the greater good you do for your federal
citizen now there's 45 million that's
but you know you do for the rest
so it's all for the collective good it's
what you should do it's not about your
rights it's about making sure you do
what's right for everybody else
does that sound familiar and i think
each of us particularly in the context
of a pandemic that's killing
millions of people
you have got to look at it and say there
comes a time
when you do have to give up
what you consider your individual right
of making your own decision
for the greater good of society now uh
there's we have all references available
a lot of credit.com there's there's a
lot to dive into here so i'm gonna try
and give you the cliff notes and gerald
you can jump in wherever you want there
were
this is also another thing of course
when you have communist socialist
regimes hey uh i wanna know in the
united states
new york chicago los angeles san
francisco big cities right pretty big
this is what usually happens with mayors
they promise more public transit they
promise more social safety nets right
yeah the left of course is the one that
wants you to be in big cities and they
want big cities to have undue influence
over the rest of the country that's why
they want to have they want to do away
with the electoral college well you see
this even in china 23 million rural
laborers were reallocated to cities in
uh somewhere between like late 50s early
60s
similar to how biden is trying to
federalize zoning laws right now
essentially create cities everywhere
again there are consistencies when you
look at when they say well no no
socialism is a bad word we mean
democratic socialism look at the
policies you're just not at the severe
point yet i guarantee you there were
people in china who thought hey
this is good the government's going to
come in and help us farm
all right
sounds nice hey they want a double steel
production in a year until you realize
that your house is being torn down
hey they want to help us
beat a virus and they're like are they
are they welding our doors shut right
why is it hot in here yeah it's weird
let's open the wind where are the
windows why are all the sparrows dead oh
god
my red breasted friend so uh let's go to
the next
nationalism this is something to the
people like you know they they dislike
with hitler and yeah hitler was a
nationalist socialist but it wasn't
really nationalism in the sense of
borders it was nationals in the sense of
race his border was the whole world well
his border was anyone who doesn't look
like you well yeah well yes like i want
to own the whole world and everybody
looked like me it wasn't me though we
can agree he was frowned upon look i'll
i'll read through the the first couple
hitler things for you okay please so he
aimed to unite the working class for
german interests right sounds good on
aryan interests wanted germany to be
entirely self-sufficient wanted social
order placing aryan race at the top and
ultimately killed political dissidents
who threatened german nationalism that's
the only way that you can get everybody
on you just kill people right right and
mal is you know not a capitalist you
know cultural revolution he was he
wasn't a nationalist right he was a so
he was a cultural revolutionist where he
wanted to upend all of their
institutions in tradition right and he
wanted to attack the four olds by the
way the the great leap forward
great reap forward that was a really bad
naming
right you should have fixed it no no no
no no great read forward to get rid of
four old i'm sorry what are you what for
old
order right reap
i don't know
him run him over with
old ideas old cultures old customs and
old habits and just to be clear you can
check the references these are the
actual words these were considered
institutions absolutely it was a mission
to get rid of these four olds old ideas
old culture old customs old habits yeah
and clinging to guns and religion right
do away with gender no no this is what
we're talking about here this is see
you're reading my note that i just oh
yeah yeah yeah so in other words he
wants to do away with old institutions
wants to do away with old norman by the
way in china yeah there is religion yeah
right so hey is there
i'm trying to think is there any
political wing today that wants to do
away with american traditions ideas uh
practices call i just i think you're the
left maybe people have been beaten down
and they feel so betrayed by government
it's not surprising then that they
get better and they claim to gods or
religion or
antipathy towards people who aren't like
that
and
a way to explain
their frustrations
yeah because in the united states it's
not like guns and religion have
played a significant role in our history
that is the history
leaving well taxation representative we
said uh we don't want to do the church
of england thing and uh we're gonna make
sure that we don't have to by using this
bad boy freedom of religion had nothing
to do with nothing today hello to my
musket uh and those who were considered
intellectuals who had ties to the west
in china right they were just they were
killed they were persecuted so again
dissidence it was about 1.6 million
people so look we still have the
scoreboard here
nationalism predicated on race right
ethno-nationalism bad and uh also just
doing away with everything that made
your nation exist like china that's bad
i still am a nationalist here in the
united states and i believe this is the
greatest nation uh on the face of the
earth however uh at this point i don't
know let's just um it's pretty bad let's
let's call the score even on nationalism
right they both get a point they both
get a point yeah two one points there
all right let's go to religion here
really quickly because this also matters
when we're comparing hitler versus mao a
lot of people say well hitler was a
christian
when they say that you know they're
stupid they don't know what wasn't he
partly jewish that's not a rumor that
was or is that not true yeah i know i
mean it's he could have fooled a lot of
people
it fooled me until just now i mean he
walked in and people were like oh is the
accountant's here
[Applause]
i'm not i am not i'm not accountant nine
i'm my day i'm sorry mine
i will do my own taxes
i am a qualified cpa but that is not my
profession
all
you know stereotypes that's true it's
okay and i did i did graduate with
honors from law school but i am not a
liar
would you like me to paint you
i paint and i do have latkes in my
lunchbox but i'm nine aeon all right i
love bagels
so hitler was raised catholic this is
where it comes from all right
now he often did quote the bible and
jesus in writings uh but he practiced
something known as positive christianity
this was an attempt to blend his
ethno-german nationalism with
christianity just to be clear the nazi
platform actually read let me read this
to you quote zapati as such stands for
positive christianity but does not
commit itself to any particular
denomination it combats the jewish
materialist spirit this in and without
us and is convinced that our nation can
achieve permanent health only from
within on the basis of the principle the
common interest before self-interest so
whenever someone says hey when you have
conservatives say that hitler was a
socialist that's that's that's their
platform it's their name and it's their
platform i dated a girl that had that
tattooed on her back
it was pretty tough to read yeah yeah
spent a lot of time back there no but i
mean she believed it yeah well look you
know what as long as she believes it
yeah she changes ways eventually it's
her truth now here's the thing positive
christianity which is what they use you
go like well that just sounds nice
that's actually heresy okay and it
resulted in what hitler trying to
control churches so hitler used religion
even though he reviled religion just to
be clear the state right church was
established to unify three branches of
protestantism uh they attempted to ban
the use of the old testament saying that
it was quote too jewish well you know
they're the story
i like the prophecies of the christ but
it's a little too jewy
yeah it is yes because in matthew 5 it
says and also kill all of the jews yes
no no i believe that's what it says no
that's what you say yeah hey you know
what we have a shower there for you nice
new fluffy tablet you're missing it's
kind of hard to jump into book two and
just ignore the first one isn't it
it's like hitler was sitting there
watching godfather too but what's
happening
i have no idea how long he's home alone
he's lost his his parents in florida
he's in new york no i don't believe the
first part
the second part fantastic i added some
of my own uh you know notes though so
this gives me some great ideas for
execution oh two chests on the head who
the thoughts yeah there you go this is
good bricks paint can down to says well
that's surefire now
um catholic priests were sent to
concentration camps catholic newspapers
were banned and hitler grew to hate
christianity
his first biographer quoted him as
saying the dogma of christianity gets
worn away before the advances of science
gradually is a miscrumble when
understanding of the universe has become
widespread zen's a christian doctrine
would be convicted of absurdity so he
hated christendom he he used it and then
he tried to destroy it now i don't think
i'm revealing anything new to you with
mao
obviously wanted to do away with not
only religion but any sort of belief in
god and that's because he replaced god
with his own image so this is what he
wrote uh well this is actually what he
said to the dalai lama which is pretty
bold
when you think about it
he said religion is poison it has two
great defects it undermines the race and
retards the progress of country tibet
and mongolia have been poisoned by it
[Laughter]
that son of a gun used the word [ __ ] i
thought he was calling him
also uh tibet and mongolia have been
poisoned by me
better poison he then sent thousands of
soldiers to loot tibet if you watch that
shitty bread pit film you probably know
about it okay oh that's what it's about
religion
although every time he shows up there in
the himalayas i just i end up with marks
on my knuckles from going
oh i know
so i don't know can we go back to them
standing for at least an hour
religion in china was essentially
replaced with the cult of mao or as
anita dunn refers to him uh her fave
best so portraits of mao were placed in
schools factories offices the study of
mao was compulsory
that's just so gross i want you to know
well why am i doing german now
you're getting confused no no no no i
want you to know every inch of my body
same guy really there were glorifying
songs that were being played and from
street speakers they were had to be sung
by school children there were parades
for mao held twice a year in tiananmen
square so look i guess this one again
we're gonna have to say is even when
we're looking at who was the worst
dictator okay uh they both
basically both did their best to outlaw
faith why because well first off not
only is that how you institute a new
form of what effectively becomes moral
decay right and you're required to be
the messianic figure but it also allows
you to remove hope and that's very
important hey socialism is a hopeless
idea yeah it's the idea that you can't
make it on your own and so you need
everyone else to do it for you for the
greater good what could possibly go
wrong with putting your fate in the hand
of others so when it comes to this you
know what we're going to call it an even
score at this
point uh so well real quickly
hitler has two the singing of songs by
school children does anybody remember
when they were doing the uh the songs
about was it fauci in the uh the vaccine
or something oh yeah what's going on
there i i don't know that sounded a
little familiar and by the way when he
was running protesters over with his
power wheels yeah exactly and also
making somebody into kind of this deity
this person who is beyond reproach that
you can't question and everything that
they tell you to do like are you guys
seeing the comparison here at all like
it's not necessarily a biden or somebody
like that who's doing it but it's vouchy
that's a good point the only difference
is mao was a better pitcher he was yeah
he could actually hit home plate yeah
so let's look at the actual deaths this
is a number that uh may surprise a lot
of people look both are bad again
horribly bad horribly bad it's just i
feel like we always spend this time on
hitler and we never spend time on
stalling on mao and pol pot on mussolini
mussolini's kind of a mussolini's a
loser we'll save him last he's the
lightweight he's the wildcat i mean yeah
he's at best tried right he's in this in
the in our brackets mussolini's just
going to be there to pad someone's
record yeah he's really he's d2 yeah
he's community college yeah he's not
even he's a juco champion so uh hitler
12 million were killed uh total in
concentration camps a lot of people they
just quote the jewish number but there
were far more people who were killed
than just the jews and 30
million more were attributed you know to
basically starvation hillary uh
hillary's killing well you know well
freudian slip that makes perfect sense
yes bill and hillary to death
back in time and killed more people now
mao does anyone know the number and i
want you guys to comment before i give
you the number because i know you heard
me give you one of the numbers earlier
right how many deaths
how many deaths at minimum let's say
under mouth didn't stop at the 45.
didn't stop at the 45. minimum 40 top
end 80
million
people
minimum thank you for clarifying
millions just making sure
more people get killed at a brawl with a
golden corral
several brawls at a golden corral
someone gets run over with a fruit cart
philadelphia eagles games that have
lesbians
they have a jail under the field so we
do i know so we've just gone through
this but do you guys see the compare
this is the problem is when people try
to we did this a long time ago i said
well hitler was a socialist and you have
all these little girls stephen crowder
things hitler was a socialist
yeah why because he said it
it was in the title i take him at his
platform yeah and the policies i mean
everything about it everything about it
was socialist and then you look at mao
and that's socialism you know that's
that's like jolt socialism twice the so
twice the communism twice the caffeine
where they just did it a little bit more
uh everything was nationalized but again
if you look at these ideas these
principles and you drink it because you
think it's cool yeah well that's what
you did this was before energy drinks
they were in a famine
so what happens here is you have to uh
look at the ideas and what they stem
from okay is mao that far off from
hitler as far as what they want to do
with the country with their vision and
not necessarily just as far as
nationalism is really the only kind of
differentiating factor as far as
ethno-nationalism if you look at what
the chinese and the japanese thought
they all believed there was really kind
of one superior asian race but that'll
be for another day
this idea was always look you put your
needs second you put your self-interest
second for the common good and by the
way we're not requesting that we're
going to ensure that you do that by
government power by coercion look we
need all of you in big cities and urban
areas so that we can make sure that we
control you and we determine where you
live what businesses can open what
businesses can close that we make sure
we uh have control over not only the
media but the educational system people
in the urban areas here the elites
they're going to be in charge of what
happens in the rural areas they're going
to tell them how to farm they're going
to tell them what they can farm they are
going to tell
which people
are allowed to farm this is something
that has been going on
really you know it's human nature but
communism and socialism just removed the
reins and allowed the worst components
of human nature to run free and this is
why anywhere it has been tried ever
it's awful uh and it's also why it's
tariff just on a smaller scale we do
have checks and balances here in the
united states
but you have eight years of obama you
have four years under donald trump and
now you have uh a couple of years under
uh joe biden
really a year a year just over gosh it
feels so much longer can you spot the
differences people said donald trump
said bad things because he would say
they were fake news did donald trump try
and get anyone removed from the air
think about that for a second
do you really i i think would be pretty
hard for someone today
to make a comparison do they make it all
the time and say yeah you know what
donald trump or ted cruz or ben carson
dead ringer for hitler i think i think
even in their alone time we all have
this when you're in your alone time and
you're kind of reflecting on what you
said and hopefully you're giving an
honest assessment of yourself you say am
i wrong about this do i have a blind
spot if
if people like jen sake of the world joe
biden of the world kamala harris says of
the world they need to duns the world
people who all work together
they're in their alone time
they've got to say okay do i really
think that these people are hitler
no no i don't
do i see a through line and similarities
between mao who these people have
praised i've praised uh and
the policies
of marxism leninism what we see
throughout
well i even have bernie sanders in my
party saying socialism isn't all that
bad of a thing and breadlines are yeah
you know what i think i'm not saying
that they're mao i'm not saying that
they're stalin but it certainly is more
of an apt comparison than donald trump
or any guy in this room to hitler
regardless of the pigment of our skin so
you know what actually looking at the
scoreboard with the deaths it's not even
close mao put one on the scoreboard for
mao mao wins mao wins oh four to two wow
and when he wins
you all lose
or as anita done refers to it win fewer
mouths to feed those wins
especially when you count those damn
sparrows
eating all the crops one billion get rid
of sparrows locust will take krs this
has been the first chapter of the great
dictator off
[Music]
well that graphic's wrong hitler didn't
hitler lost well everybody thought
hitler was going to win i think it was
just they wanted the pun of final
solution comment below guys look the
best thing you can do for the youtube
algorithm comment below who do you want
to see next we're thinking probably
stalin but who would you like to see in
this comparison we'll probably do them
once a week yeah uh if you want to see
them if you don't i know it can be a
little bit nerdy that's why we provide
all of the references but you know what
i think you just got more out of this
than you would from
19 years of college um so we're actually
now smash that like button before we go
yeah
hit it hit it
hit it
hit it hit it hit it hit it hit it there
you go
we're gonna go play steven no sports
youtube piss off
you